what are the top obstacles to Peaceful
coexistence of Israelis and Palestinians
the the occupation comes to mind the
strategical policies come to mind
the seeds comes to mind the asymmetry of
the Judiciary comes to mind
the whole the whole system needs to be
dismantled I will quote my dear friend
who's uh who's a lawyer who says you
know the solution Justice comes about
through
recognition return
and redistribution
there are millions of Palestinian
refugees who are living in excruciating
circumstances and refugee camps around
the world there are thousands of
Palestinian prisoners
um
who are held in prisons for defending
their homes hundreds of which are held
without charge or trial by the way there
are many Palestinians who get killed in
broad daylight with no recourse
journalists and Medics and everyday
people not just the fire the Freedom
Fighters
we need again recognition return and
redistribution and peace comes about
when when
when they stop killing us when they stop
keeping us in a cage I mean that's
that's quite simple can you describe
recognition redistribution return and
redistribution return return rate of
return right the right of return to all
of the Palestinian refugees to their
homes you know when I'm driving around
Haifa and I see my grandmother's uh home
that's now turned into a restaurant you
know I could have you know I I made a
joke in one of my essays recently that
had I had that I could have had it all
you know beats front views her smug
attitude you know she grew up by the she
grew up by the Sea after she relocated
the High phones after you know
you know they're lucky I don't want
netanyahu's home but I just want my home
I just want my home we want to return I
also wouldn't there needs you know and
like
I believe in the 1960s the Israeli
government classified 90 of all of
historic Palestine as state-owned land
this is
all land that was owned by Palestinian
farmers who have cultivated their lands
for decades you know since the
establishment of the Israeli State there
has been
uh Jewish only towns popping up every
few years and not one town not one
Palestinian town has emerged we are even
those of us who have Israelis Israeli
citizenship who live outside of the wall
are encircled and cannot have their
natural Community growth in their towns
that needs to change that needs to
change you mentioned the wall can you
describe the wall the wall is a nine
meter high cement wall
that was finished in 2003 and if you're
American you've probably heard the
whitewash sanitized version of the name
which is the security wall
but it's uh it's the wall that literally
has stolen
thousands of Dunhams of land and has
ripped apart Families my mother is a
poet or was a poet at some point and she
had this poems she she published in the
paper
Called Love behind the wall and it
describes you know it's it's a poem but
it describes a real life situation
of uh two families that who lived right
across the street from each other but
were then separated by the wall and they
would fly balloons
um you know to see each other from each
side of the wall or something like that
this
although it sounds absurd but it's the
reality for many Palestinian families
whose lives were torn apart to his
livelihoods also were torn apart uh by
the wall maybe this is a good
opportunity to talk about the the legal
classifications for Palestinians
you know um Israel much like any other
Colonial entity uh was has Divine has
divided
and fragmented the Palestinian people
um as I said earlier I have a blue ID
which means I'm a resident
a friend of mine who lives in heifa for
example two hours away from me 150
kilometers not nothing too bad in this
country
has an Israeli citizenship he can you
know travel he can enter the West Bank
he can
um
do a lot more he's a citizen he can vote
if he wants to not that we want to
um you know I always tease my friends or
you can go to Italy without without a
Visa because you have an Israeli
citizenship but you know they battle
National and race or they battle
um crime in their own communities
because of police negligence they they
battle land conference land confiscation
and have battled confiscations in the
50s whereas somebody with a green ID
somebody from the West Bank
uh cannot leave the West Bank
cannot go anywhere without a special
permit and lives Behind These Walls and
even within the West Bank
there was the bank I think hilariously
George Bush uh described it as Swiss
cheese because
of the Halls every every few every 100
meters there's a new settlement or
there's a new military checkpoint so
even if you live behind the wall in the
West Bank with your green ID even though
you're you're robbed of your right to
movement you still even can't move from
town to town within the West Bank
without encountering settler violence or
military violence while you're crossing
the checkpoints and so on and so forth
and then the last category we have is
people who live in we were talking about
over 2 million people who live in an
open air prison
um
who have no right to movement but also
have no access to clean water water and
no access to
supplies no access to good food no
access to Good Health Care and so on and
so forth so routinely get bombarded
every few years
um
is like two hours away from my house it
feels like an absolute far away planet
because it's so isolated from the rest
of the country so imagine all of these
different legal statuses fragmenting
um your everyday identity and creating
different challenges and obstacles for
you to deal with for each group to deal
with
you know it's amazing and impressive
that despite these Colonial barriers the
the real cement ones
and the you know the barriers in the
mind despite all of these barriers the
Palestinian people have made have
maintained their national identity for
70 years that is incredibly impressive
and it also sends a message that as long
as we have a boot on our neck we are
going to continue fighting you know
violence cracking down on refugee camps
bombarding refugee camps is only gonna
bring about more violence so West Bank
is a large region where a lot of
Palestinian people live and then there
are settlements sprinkled throughout and
those settlements have walls around them
yeah for security cameras and security
guards security guards almost a million
sellers in the West Bank and so what are
the different cities here if you can
mention in the West Bank in the West
Bank
Bethlehem Hebron Jericho Annapolis
they have their own stories they have
their own histories yeah and it's
fascinating also how interconnected they
are you know like a friend of mine Mona
Almighty recently did a a documentary
report on the day that Haifa fell during
the Zionist Invasion the hagana
um
led the Palestinian residents of Haifa
down to the city center
and as absurd as it sounds
those of them who stood on the right
side of the street were forced into cars
that took them to multiple stops that
would later become multiple refugee
camps the last of which was Janine
refugee camp and
um those who stood on the left side of
the street were forced to board uh boats
that took them to Lebanon to become
refugee camps refugees there
last month we saw the Israeli Army
invade Janine in maybe the largest
military invasion of Janine since 2002
um
and they killed many people they
attacked Medics and journalists in broad
daylight on camera they have
destroyed infrastructure and it was all
very painful but I think the most
compelling aspect
of the real engineering was what
followed Israeli soldiers at night held
their megaphones and uh
instructed hundreds of Palestinians to
flee their homes and they told them if
you don't leave if you don't have your
hand up in the air you will get shot and
they were forced to leave their homes in
the camp and walk so God knows where
I can guarantee you because the nakaba
is not that old I can guarantee you that
some people who were marching
away from their camps were chased away
from their homes in the camp engineering
were some of the same people who were
chased away from the homes in Haifa in
the first place this Perpetual exile
that Palestinian people
continue to live is is unbearable I mean
in my case my grandmother was removed
from her home in Haifa in 48 and then
she moved from city city and then in
2009 she saw half of her home taken over
by Israeli soldiers my grandmother died
in 2020 and two months later we got the
next
expulsion order from the Israeli Court
I'm quite ashamed to admit that I was
relieved my grandmother had died because
I did not want her 103 years old at the
time to go through yet another nakabe
and this is the fact for so many
Palestinians regardless of where they
are on the map
if I may read the description of the
situation in Janine and maybe you can
comment so this is on July 3rd 4th and
5th just reading Washington Post
description so this was an Israeli
military incursion to Janine The Raid
included more than 1 000 soldiers backed
by drone strikes making it Israel's
largest such operation in the West Bank
since the end of the second Palestinian
Uprising in 2005.
the Israeli military said it dismantled
hundreds of explosive cleared hundreds
of weapons destroyed underground
hideouts and confiscated hundreds of
thousands of dollars in quote Terror
funds many of the 50 Palestinians who
have attacked Israelis since the start
of the year have come from Janine camp
and the surrounding area Palestinian
attacks inside Israel have killed 24
people this year U.N experts describe
the genie in operation as collective
punishment in quotes
for the Palestinian people amounting to
egregious violations of international
law
many
of the more than 150 Palestinians killed
by Israelis this year have also come
from these communities Palestinian
Fighters say they need arms to defend
themselves against the Israeli
occupation and Military incursions into
the camp during which Palestinian
civilians including children have been
killed so those are the
I would say different perspectives
on the many people on both sides who
have been killed many more Palestinians
can you comment more about the situation
I mean I think the The Washington Post
article is a little bit more uh
you know careful than other than other
media
that came out recently about Janine I
think you know I was listening to our
Reuters radio show and they failed to
ever mention the occupation I don't I
don't even think this paragraph
mentioned that Janine is under
occupation by the by the Israeli forces
by the Israeli regime I think this is
the most important piece of context that
gets
um obscured in our media reporting is
these cities these refugee camps are
under illegal occupation the Israeli
Army has no business being there in the
first place
um that is the most that is the
departure point that is the most
important piece of context that will
answer to you why these people
um are arming themselves many of which
by the way lived through the 2002
Massacre
um and bombardment of Janine and grew up
in the
um violence
um
the the context that Palestine is under
occupation that these Palestinian cities
are under occupation that they have to
deal with land seizures at all times
that they cannot leave their towns
um without a special permit all of this
will give context to the violence and
you know
the thousands of Israeli soldiers that
raided the camp that day
that traumatized an entire generation
they think they will quell that
generation they think that with such
Bloodshed and such barbaric violence
destroying infrastructure attacking
Medics killing people left and right
they think
with this kind of Terror that they can
you know quell people tell people that
you know they can guarantee that these
kids are not going to grow up and resist
but that's the opposite of what happens
one thing about Palestinian people
they will not compromise their dignity
you know these people live in
any live in dire excruciating
circumstances
and it is so courageous in my opinion
that they even think
um to defend themselves against one of
the most lethal one of the most
sophisticated armies in the world
against the nuclear state that can wipe
them out in the matter of seconds but
it's not at the end of the day it's not
even about courage it's about survival
they don't do this because you know of
machismo or because of uh heroic
Tendencies it's because this is about
survival
so the degree there's violence it's
about survival absolutely absolutely I
think if there is no if there was no
occupation there would be no violence
it's it's quite obvious and again people
understand this I mean like we saw on
Twitter in in the recent months uh all
of these Israeli uh propagandists who
had tweeted pictures of like little
girls with guns in Ukraine and like
women making bombs in Ukraine and and
young men carrying their rifles in
Ukraine and praising them as Heroes post
very similar pictures of Palestinians
um and calling them terrorists
it's glaring the double standard I don't
even need to linger on it well
the double standard is glaring
but I also think the glorification of
violence is questionable
there's a balance to be struck of course
but
yeah I mean I don't what I don't I don't
think I don't think we should be
glorifying violence uh at all but I
don't think we should be normalizing
violence either
uh I think that's that's that's what it
is you know I'll tell you a story
I was interviewing a person whose
brother was killed by the Israeli
military during uh Israeli raid
on their Village and
the person was so concerned about
whether I was gonna report
that
her brother allegedly had a Molotov
cocktail in his hand
and I found it absolutely insane
absolutely
absurd that we can just glance over the
fact that there is again a foreign
military
in tanks with rifles and snipers
invading The Village at 4am in the
morning shooting live ammunition at
people's houses throwing tear gas that
we can just glance over it's normal we
could just report on it no problem
nobody's gonna badge an eyebrow
but
the fact that
potentially somebody might have picked
up a Molotov cocktail to throw it at
this invading Army is where we draw the
line it says a lot it says a lot about
whose violence is normalized is accepted
is institutionalized is
glorified event right then you walk
around Tel Aviv and you see all of the
plaques plastered around then around the
streets of the country of the city
celebrating the battles that they had
won the massacres that they had enacted
against the Palestinian people but God
forbid God forbid Palestinians have any
kind of similar sentiment
so on July 4th during this intense
period a Palestinian rammed a car into
pedestrians at a bus stop in Tel Aviv
injuring eight people before being shot
dead by a passerby
also that night Hamas fire rock is into
Israel and then Israel responded with
strikes on what it said was an
underground weapon site so just to give
some context to the Intensive
violence happening here what do you
think about Hamas firing Rockets into
Israel
well it's the framing makes it seem as
though like
unprovoked Hamas is like firing Rockets
onto Israel regards to what I think of
Hamas obviously but unprovoked but
that's not the case the propagation is
the fact that they are forced to live in
a cage
that they have no access to clean water
they have no access to basic rights no
access to uh Imports no access to
anything
um that they can't leave they're living
in a densely populated
Enclave that was deemed uninhabitable by
the U.N that was deemed an open air
prison
um so the rockets in any case are
retaliation for the seeds let's start
there but again this is just to prove my
point violence begets violence
Palestinian people are not
violent people we are not violent people
at the core and I think you know what
serves this narrative is islamophobia is
like xenophobia towards Arabs which we
don't have like I don't have the luxury
you know to like to write laws about
um by the way I'm I'm quite I'm quite
you know frustrated by this uh I am I am
preoccupied and the Palestinian people
are preoccupied
um with the material violence that we
have to deal with on the day-to-day the
demolitions the bombings uh the
imprisonment that's what we're
distracted with and and busy with that
we can't even talk about the racism
um The Casual racism against the
anti-palestinian racism being in the
media on social media and diplomatic
circles and but all of this all of this
racism that has gone unchecked has not
been regulated
um for decades allows for these tropes
to continue in which Palestinians are
promoted as these like barbaric
terrorists and the only way we could
remedy uh that situation is to is by
marketing them as these like defenseless
victims but the fact of the matter is
isn't is not this simplistic Palestinian
people are human beings who should enjoy
a full spectrum of humanity which in
includes raids which includes the
sustain which includes happiness and joy
and laughter it includes celebration
which includes
um all of these things but we're not
allowed this but we are doing exactly
what any people throughout history who
have been oppressed who have been
colonized who have been occupied have
done and continue to do as we see in
Ukraine which is celebrated by
mainstream media I'm sorry to uh keep
reiterating this point but
you know at this point uh
I am quite you know
exhausted by how exceptional Palestine
and Palestinian resistance is when the
world tells me time and time again that
it doesn't have a problem with violence
it just has a problem with who does that
violence
do you in your mind and in the way you
see this region draw distinction between
the people in power versus the regular
people so you mentioned the Palestinian
people
is there something you can comment on on
Hamas and the PLO
uh do you see them as fundamentally
different
from the people
uh what does Hamas do well where did
they fall short
I think governments uh wherever globally
any are different from people no
government is a true reflection of its
people I think uh
you know this is even true in the case
of like Arab countries that normalize
with Israel in many of the cases there
are
um unelected governments
I think the Palestinian Authority
continues to fail
um I think there are subcontractors the
Israeli regime through their security
coordination
and also I'd like to use this as an
opportunity to comment a little bit on
the
on the analogy thing not to like
stray away from the question but you
know
um the Palestinian Authority
two years ago killed an opposition
activist named nizarban at
it was a horrendous crime and I was in
Ramallah
with the people protesting against the
Palestinian Authority and at some point
they had their batons the Palestinian
Authority police and they beat us with
it and many of the people on the crowd
were liking the Palestinian Authority to
Zionism
I think people this is what people do
we when they are confronted by a great
evil they liken it to some other great
evil and this is where the Hitler
analogy came from
um again I don't think it's like the
best strategy moving forward but I
refuse you know to be
uh
you know criminalized for a little
sentence
but to linger on those in power so one
of the criticisms towards Hamas and PLO
towards the Israeli government
at least the current coalition
government
is um
that there's a lot of incentive to sort
of perpetuate violence to maintain power
there's a hunger for power and and
maintaining that power amongst the
powerful that's the way power works so
is there um a worry you have about
those in power not having the best
interests of its people so those in
power of the PLO Hamas not
uh not being incentivized towards peace
towards Justice
foreign
you know looking at the PA's action
today it tells you a great deal about
what they're interested in and what
they're not interested in and maybe yeah
the occupation is in their best interest
um and you can infer similar things
looking at at Hamas but the two the two
these two entities virtually have no
power even Hamas
um Yani there is you know the the
context that Hamas is permitted through
by international law uh to use armed
resistance blah blah blah does that mean
Hamas is like equipped to govern Russia
I don't think so does that mean that uh
people around Palestine necessarily want
to want to live under uh
Hamas rule in 2006 Hamas was
democratically elected I don't know if
that's still the case today
um there is there's a lot to be said but
neither of these entities have any real
power
um
in in perpetuating they don't the the
only the only body that has access that
can flip the switch and all of this
equation
is Israelis you know they're the ones
who are keeping people in a case they're
the ones who are
um wrapping the West Bank with the with
a wall
um everything else to me is just
secondary regardless of what I think
personally of any of those people I know
personally for me I I the world I
Envision not the spouse in the world I
Envision is a world that goes beyond
States
um that goes beyond this uh uh framing
of power this this hierarchy in which uh
some people will over other people this
whole idea of nation states be it Israel
or any other nation states it's
it's
futile it's not good it's exclusive I
think that we can achieve a better world
than that
well the you know how do you do a better
world they actually if you just Linger
on that like what
what
the politically speaking geopolitically
you have to have representation of the
people you have to have
laws you have to have leaders in
governing bodies that enact those laws
and all those kinds of things you
probably need to have militaries to
protect
the people can you not imagine a world
without militaries I can imagine it but
we're not in that world
yeah I'm not saying you know I have all
the answers or a PowerPoint in my pocket
you know with the instructions but I I'm
saying the world I'd like to live in is
one that transcends borders is one
that you know does not necessitate
militaries that doesn't necessitate all
of these
um prisons of these walls all of these
Priestess laws so you don't think
violence is a fundamental part of human
nature that emerges
and like combined with the hunger for
power
I do think I do think that both of these
things are like truly intrinsic to to
human beings they also do think there is
a way to move Beyond them I'm not saying
I have the answers
um I'm tempted Safeway but
but you have a hope that there doesn't
have to be War yeah yeah in the world
definitely definitely